hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to tear down
a game of utter destruction and
terrifying capabilities in the palm of
your hand or something like that i don't
know you blow [ __ ] up and it blows you
up and it blows you away then when it
all blows
what happened to me okay about let me
i'll let the game explain itself i get i
did not know this was just
oh my god
what this isn't about this isn't about
it all
i mean i appreciate this is a credit
sequence i thought this was an about you
could help me because obviously i can't
even explain a game
i've been doing youtube videos for eight
years i can't explain anything that i'm
doing properly it probably should be the
beginning of most video games that i
play
you know tell people who made it give
credit where credit's due
and we're fading away okay so as we
learned
nothing this game is about blowing stuff
up that's all i know
i don't know if i should do the campaign
or the sandbox or challenges
i don't know
good god that's pretty
this game has no right being this pretty
what the hell is this about oh my god
look at that is that ray tracing
it's retracing enabled it's running like
a turd okay that's better
god damn that's pretty oh
wow that is some good stuff um how do i
blow it up
how do i destroy this world do i just go
home cause clearly that's not my home
or at least i hope that's not my home
why am i walking home
oh you won't stop me
you're stopping me in the water i'm in
the water now
i'm in the water i'm in the
water god why are you so pretty why are
you
so god damn pretty you tree
[ __ ] what right do you have who do you
think you are being this attractive
stop it you seductive tree [ __ ] where
am i
i'm coming after you i'm gonna be all up
in you
all right i've made it to the top i'm
higher than you therefore i'm better
than you everyone knows
oh this is my home well thank you tree
for the assist i would not have known
that
had i not climbed you my legs oh
there's fall damage why this game is
much more intricate than i thought it
was i thought i was just gonna be
blowing stuff
up which it might be hold the drag open
doors where could i blow it up
you know i was misled on the amount of
blowing up that this game was gonna
present to me
oh i'm so strong i could have ripped
that tree out by its roots
don't think i still can't because i will
all right
open door is this my home pick up your
tools
pick up my tools what is this fire
fire extinguisher well that would solve
problems i want to cause problems
wow oh look at the foam
this game looks really good why why does
it look
good stop looking good
oh ah okay not a penis first thing
this looks like it's about to be a penis
it's an axe
yeah you see it okay and hammer
okay replace the fuse to turn on power
oh hello no you tricked me
oh i'm sorry i don't want to kill
anymore
i don't want to hi do you hold the
secret
use tool why oh die i don't want to kill
anymore
well that took two hits i'll do the same
as i did to your brother
get this all squared away hello okay
will the sledge
help me replace this no
okay go inside and check messages why
but why though
because i have a job because this is my
job
wow oh that's not good my livelihood
shut up
don't shut up hello
tracy gas bill gas bill just dropped on
the floor
why honestly i'm not sure we can make it
through the month who are you
mom oh mom oh okay just came in sounds
kind of fishy but we need the money
up for it good evening my name is gordon
woo
general manager at the evertides mall i
have a slight problem with an old
building that's blocking our plans for a
new wing and i'd need someone to knock
it over
i'm sure this is legal i need it done by
tomorrow and i'd be evil a little bit
more standard
for some extra discretion quick
execution and uncomfortable working
hours
say no more mr wu i will
execute that's pretty far away now you
know i
ain't gonna ask you many questions
because i don't need to know that much
about
it oh my god
i'm going in the ocean yes
i hate it i regret it hello where am i
well this was a mistake
excuse me i went out please thank you
climb up on my truck
why i just like to be high up okay what
does this
say or finish oh municipality folk
museum well that seems
important 6.3 meters too tall
propane tanks explode when thrown great
good to know throw object
oh my god his discretion is
not occurring there's no discretion i'll
tear this whole city to the ground
if it keeps discretion discretion has
been
and will continue to be advised let's
just take out the base layers
if i learned any how if i learned
anything from playing
battlefield whatever it's that you aim
ow you aim for the supports
get the structural stability down
to poop levels ow and then
everything will come tumbling down
actually i don't know if that's how you
do it in battlefield i don't
really play those games well you're
still standing
good thing i haven't even unleashed my
most deadly attack
yeah i can't take this fire [ __ ] uh
there's a dick
no it was the dick breaker
looks like the dick breaker struck again
nothing we can do against this menace
is this better come tumbling down that's
all i gotta say
tumble like a weed tumble [ __ ]
oh it's holed up by that oh well i'll
take care of you
the deckbreaker strikes again
ah get away get get gone
really this can i break brick with a
sled i can't break brick
well that's dumb i'll go get what can
break brick a three two one
you piece of [ __ ] if you're not gonna
crumble you're gonna
tumble tumble damn it
humble tumbled tombol you
this is impossible how would any human
new fridge
is it what new it ain't i don't know who
said
new this not unknew it it ain't new
what's in the shed only one way to find
out
here's marky the dickbreaker has
penetrated another house
he cannot be stopped i don't like that
nickname i think it's a bad one what
happens if i load up this place and then
then blow what happens if i load and
blow
would that do anything just a little bit
of the old extreme discretion at play
no one just wonk this thing around why
don't i
no one's gonna know a thing
oh fire
fire it can catch on fire
yeah that helps why would i want to put
that out
why would i want to this is the point i
am a destroyer
the dick breaker breaker of dicks i love
this game
this is fantastic well i just got to sit
back and wait right
watch the world burden down might as
well cut down some trees or something i
don't know
bam get out of here municipality folk
museum
no one cares about folk music anymore go
in the ocean
you go tree you go in the ocean you go
the ocean if you know what's good for
you
can i drag you can i pick up this tree
please tell me i can
i'm not that strong though i could have
ripped that tree out by its roots
are you done yet my god oh my god come
on
burn baby burn
all right i'll help out quite satisfying
i gotta give it that hey job's a job you
know
there probably was a lot better way to
go about this but
i don't know what that is and uh i don't
have time to go back
and only forward with me it's the only
way i know how to live my life is moving
forward and that's how i'm moving and
that's how i'm living
a little more come on come on break
break damn you great am i on fire
yay mission accomplished get to the
escape vehicle
escape vehicle with no point in keeping
that building uh uh
erect if you ask me building meant to
come down
building needed to come down buildings
should have come down
faster eight minutes intense i was way
too long but hey we'll be able to pay
our gas bill
ooh i do like this warehouse i didn't
like it at first but now i
really actually like it i've always
wanted to have like a loft style big
open warehouse kind of deal see
according to the police
the perpetrators did a quick job on the
old building
an investigation has been opened
okay whatever i don't know hey ma ma
oh what a morning shouldn't have taken
that job i knew something wasn't right
that building was under cultural
heritage protection and the demolition
is now part of a criminal investigation
miss turdy man at the police just sent
me this photo
they must have caught you on the traffic
camera heading towards the mall the very
last thing we need right now is an
investigation
i tried sweet talking her and she
thought she could get the case dropped
but ask for a favor in return
i don't know what she wants but just do
it hello miss turdyman
just so you know i don't usually do this
but i'm
stuck on a case and i feel like i should
try something new
i've been investigating lawrence lee jr
over tax
i didn't turn off my alarm
that's annoying how about you use your
skills to borrow the computers over
elite chemicals so that i can finally
access this customer registry
and sort this mess out if you do this
for me i'll make sure your
little blunder will be forgotten okay
sounds good man
sounds good you got it turdman the
dickbreaker and turdman working together
i'm going to destroy this and there's
nothing you can do to stop me
absolutely nothing i will not be stopped
oh
there we go oh it does kind of flop okay
that's good
anyway what was i doing who am i where
are you my hair
hello stop stop stop
stop thank you what am i doing some kind
of computer
some kind of computer needs blown up
hello thank you
excuse me oh well that was easy
[Music]
oh i'm out of body i'm out of my body
hello
computer lee's office upper floor okay
i don't know how i did that people
better watch out i got some kind of
powers
hello quick save why am i quick saving
do i have to kill someone in here must
be locked
ah brick i can't even come close to
dealing with that
yes i can hello hi goodbye
ow excuse me pardon
me hey what's up coffee
coffee for i'm taking this this is mine
now
get that out the door it'll be fine
oh grab valuable okay
i didn't know i could just steal things
that's who i am
oh fifty shades of capitalism
be still my groin that looks like a
computer
marina warehouse leasing contract
gone paper jam they're destroyed
there's an attic and apparently
something's in the attic
so i'm gonna create a staircase real
quick here her
okay you know i gotta try a different
direction here herbert
there we go oh lee's tax deductible
finch in front how does anyone get up on
this attic what are you talking about
there's no getting up on that attic you
don't have to worry about telling people
not to go up there because
how are they gonna uh there was like a
way there was like a you know it was
like a
i saw a thing a bam pipes
that's what i saw yep all right where is
this taking me
oh down i'm an idiot this way i guess
hope i can't climb that ah
all right whatever i'll go in the front
that's completely wide open i guess
not happy about it though but whatever
sled
i did it corrosive chemicals huh how
corrosive
not very apparently it's not even
quoting anything
where's the corrosion where's the cro
crows me
cruz garbage sad
terrible what is this what kind of
safety protocols is this oh hi
okay bottle of golf myra i love
golf golf myra hello
hello hello ah a damn why
was i supposed to be sneaky ooh speaking
of sneaky
i see you there oh ow
are these explody if that was i would
have gone up
real quick okay there's something going
on in there there's something happening
hey let me up come on look come on come
on let me there we go
there's something going on here drive
yeah
trying to be oh oh my god how where
what oh i don't know what that what in
the world am i doing
why am i doing this do i need to get up
there is that the only way to get up
there
what kind of nightmare building design
is this
holy crap got it
get out of here wonk take this
a-hole yeah that just goes to nothing oh
it broke
that's her excuse it broke you're gonna
be paying this back for you oh my god i
almost
died but now i won't
ah well that didn't blow up everything
it's supposed to blow up everything oh
everything blew i'm almost dead
i really shouldn't do any of what i'm
doing
but i'm a pro ow i'm a professional and
i will not be swayed
by limitations such as mission
objectives
all right i'm gonna run now oh don't
worry police little officer
i took care of everything
[Music]
breaking news hit and run no fun for lee
sun breaking at lee chemicals the
perpetrator
caused property damage and
managed to get away with electronic
equipment all right whatever that sounds
pretty good
i got a new message all right the
customer registry
indicates that lee's worked almost
exclusively with a single client
recently the client is only referred to
as bt and no further details so i really
have to bother you with one more favor
all right man whatever yeah that sounds
good i'll go back
uh not like i care was there some
information about the security in that
little blurb that i didn't read
whatever man let's get in hey what is
this what
oh what oh
are you kidding me uh vulnerability
detected
[Music]
target acquired i'm gonna go in the back
way
where all the rocks is i can break
through rocks
but i won't rocks didn't hurt me
they deserve better oh this looks
important can i break it
hello yeah
what's going on there just hidden cash
man i'm really good at finding all the
hidden stuff not trying to
just happens i'm so goddamn good at
games oh yes
please i don't know what i'm about to do
with this thing but uh
wobble womb yeah yeah i just got
brown oh my god
yes oh my god
all right whatever i brought oops ah not
exactly what i meant to do i meant to
put that there so i could climb up it
but actually i don't even know if i can
climb up this thing oh i can't okay
all right i found my way in hello who's
here
hi what is that
i got a circular saw
okay so what's this security system i've
heard so much about
hey what the hell yeah all right
okay you won't play hardball play the
hardest ball of all
hardball nice hello
hi what's up here failed test results
wonkas
uh any anything of value
all right cool what's my oh
wired alarm boxes security arrives 60
seconds after alarm is triggered make
sure to plan ahead
whatever break things not like i need to
worry about it maybe i could go over to
the dam maybe i could break the dam
that'd be cool that'd be pretty cool is
anyone gonna stop me
like a big yellow wall anyone gonna try
to stop me
i'm gonna turn off the whole city's
power oh it's open this was a mistake
for you
oh what the hell oh oh agent b4
oh wallet i'm i'm a goddamn thief
oh you should not have let me in here oh
this is gonna go
terribly for all of you here we go
okay good yeah i survived that
all right that's sturdy just checking
the integrity wonkas wankus
anybody wankers wonkas i'll take that
distance laser
awesome what was i doing there oh
there's still power here
was there no point to me destroying the
whole city's infrastructure because i'm
going to be really cross if that's the
case
so there's some kind of alarm this you
shouldn't have put this here
god you shouldn't have put that there
that's going to take us down a bit
uh excuse me that's good
this thing's got some giddy up all right
well now i've thoroughly destroyed my
way across that
all right no one will ever get back here
what are you pick up target key reader
what do you go to well i have a funny
feeling that's gonna do a thing
before i can get away with doing the
thing
so i'm gonna investigate this place
[Music]
okay so there's some kind of like wires
or something to this
so if i pick this up i've got 60 seconds
to get here
okay whatever oh
okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna go dude i
got this
this is easy watch this this way
i know whatever you thought you could
stop me
you can't even stop yourself i don't
know what that means but
sounds profound yes i'm the best
best ever oh yeah oh my god i'm the
greatest
excuse me pardon me oh yoinkus yeah
thank you for the contribution oh sweet
god you all wish you were as good as me
but you're not and that's so sad
oh my god
oh my god you guys all suck
i am
amazing i nailed it you reached a new
rank a new tool has been delivered
[Music]
oh you can upgrade your tools at the
computer i can
okay wait before i do that let me look
at my tools sledge
no upgrade available upgrade no upgrade
oh yeah
oh yeah just all of it what else am i
gonna spend my money on i got so much
money i've stolen so much stuff they
turned off the gas i can't even make a
proper coffee anymore we really need to
bring in more clients
i'll reach out to gordon and see if he
has something else i haven't heard back
from the police
the thing sorted yeah ma
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah ma oh yeah
gordon that's right
thanks for helping me out with that
building the police was snooping around
a little but it seemed to have cooled
off now and we can finally start
construction
i actually have another job for you see
i bought this yacht recently but it's
too
large for the marina and the board said
there's no space for a new dock
could you use your demolition skills
again remove one of the
timeshare cabins if the original
documentation also disappeared then
ta-da like it was never there okay sure
at least this one seems well it doesn't
seem legit but it seems a little less
nefarious than breaking a historical
museum in the middle of the night
i didn't know we had a boat our company
has a boat we got a demolition
boat that's dope uh
i'm robbing this house this is what i've
decided i'm doing
peek-a-boo kind of yes i can dig the
fish
ow water in you what are in you
i know you got goodies in here somewhere
so just give me the goodies okay
no eating at the desk yeah sure whatever
you say wangus
hello this desk no okay
all right so you're playing hard to get
uh what's going on here
one gordon permit again other questions
okay oh
primary target i didn't know that this
was my primer what do you mean oh
god oh the blow
and not and not blowing
doesn't seem to be blowing well how do i
i didn't even know this was where i was
supposed to go it didn't even say on
them oh it does stand on the map okay
whatever
usually this kind of works
wow whatever you know it's fine create a
way for me to
get it out of the building i guess i
could just load it onto the boat
i suppose let's get it out get it out to
get it out the window
there she goes there she goes not in the
bush okay let's get this thing going oh
my god
there's gotta be a better way there's
gotta be
okay if i like wiggle waggle apparently
i'm pushing it with my
titanic balls right now okay okay
oh no hurdle hurdle hurdle hurdle
turtle okay okay roll it do not go in
the ocean
please go into my boat please go into my
boat
into my boat into the boat oh
do not go in the water all right into
the boat okay it's in the boat got it
okay that is secured
nail that and crack that open in my
leisure
i thought i was just robbing a house i
didn't think i was actually doing
anything important
hello well they left the mp3 player
there so that's their fault
mine now finders keepers as wise men
once said
okay those are mine all right
how community building huh is there some
kind of cultural heritage to this place
you know i feel about cultural heritage
okay well i know they're hiding
something
big buckworth there's some big valued
item that they're definitely not given
to me
i'm gonna find it oh attic i knew it
had to be something hello hi
oh a gun a gun
look at me a gun hello drive vehicle why
why not i was supposed to destroy one of
you how about
all of you valuable
valuable nah not even an attic basement
that's the water that doesn't help me
which one of these was i supposed to
kablooie okay this is the one that's
supposed to go down
all right well what if i just detach it
from the
pier and then break the supports
underneath it
well there goes the pier i just gotta
smash the supports and
uh down she goes
oh my god i'm gonna die holy crap
oh oh my god
are you really holding that up oh not
for long
there she goes oh that's oh
you tell me that a building floats
because it's made of
wood you think i'm stupid you think i'm
dumb
someone's looking at this like it's
still salvageable that's good to live in
honey this time sure was a good
investment i swear
can't drive this all right time to hit
the old dusty trail
la da da what's an optional thing just
taking some of the pier with me don't
mind me
gotta find this optional bozo going on
here
oh what's up in this place well i'm a
little confused but uh
whatever what am i doing am i going on
this boat can i drive this boat oh
please tell me i can drive this boat yes
please thank you i love it
no one's stopping me no one is
preventing anything that's happening
this is my world my world
okay uh land ho
i guess hello i'm not supposed to be
here am i
this is not part of the objective it's
probably the next mission comes here
but here i am anyway so shut up and tell
me where the goods are
goods whoa large
say largo safe how do i open
the save as us says all of my
destructive potential and i can't even
open a safe maybe i gotta blow it do i
gotta blow it
i'll blow it fire in the hole
ow that hurt
you know if i didn't know any better
i'd say that this isn't working all
right what if i load it up on a forklift
and also put it onto my boat
can i do that oh my god land on me
please
okay oh my god all right i'm gonna take
this big four key
lower it all the way down i'm gonna
scoop this bad boy
up we have it no we do not we do not
have it this is not
having it just gotta i mean it's gonna
go in the drink let's not put it in the
water
preferably there was a smaller forklift
that i thought i saw i'm gonna go get
that
that yeah there i see it zoom in on that
it's right there there target acquired
turn on bloodlust vision i'm not going
to be very angry but
make it seem like i am where am i i
don't see myself do i exist am i
invisible is that why no one stops me
i'm not lining her up linus tech tips
come on
okay and scoot oh my god are you
at all serious what if i put it on the
forklift what if i don't
forklift to it what if i put it on the
forklift
okay that's gotta work right that's
gotta work
let's just roll it that's how you do
safes good
you roll em that's okay as long as it's
on there
oh we're top heavy we're top heavy we're
tipping oh my god all right
step three uh drive tiny [ __ ] forklift
into the ocean
and then go back to big dick forklift
like we originally intended
okay all right
see you nerd get no go get
out go
okay all right back to big dick mode all
right we're gonna put this
down and we're gonna put that on this so
that we
don't have to worry about lining it up
perfectly it'll just
already be lined up
actually will that just be wedged in
there i i think it might be
oh yeah yeah we got it okay we got it
we're on the way baby
we're out of here oh i just push it what
if i just push it i'll just push it the
whole way
whatever that's fine it works oh
yeah we're fine if you could open that
gate for me
all right now how i'm gonna get it onto
the boat is another question but i think
if i got the first one i think i can get
this one too
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right
probably got to go mono amano from here
but that's okay i'm ready for it you
better make room on that boat
she's uh about to take on some weight
there we go yeah you're not going in the
drink you're not going in
i know you're not watch out little safe
i thought you were big before but
apparently no all right
let's get this up come on okay we are
loaded to the tits
is that it we get out of here right
proof by dumping the safes in the ocean
[Music]
okay good let's get out yeah yeah
oh
that tree is going to die your time has
come tree
it was your mistake to exist in the
first place so
i'm sorry you wronged me and it's only
right that i come
to pay back
oh you're tough okay
slightly less climax there yeah
get in the ocean the river all right so
actually i'm gonna end that there
because my
my rampage of destruction has reached
its natural conclusion
i now have a gun and it can only go
downhill from here so thank you
everybody so much for watching this game
is very fun
straight up this game is good time
there's really nothing else to say about
it this is just fun
and the fact that there's a story behind
it that's nuts
i don't know how they figured they could
do that but they did it let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
if you want to see more games like this
give me suggestions of them
in the comments and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you